hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the structure of the
chloroplast i just did a video uh
recently on the structure of
mitochondria so make sure you also check
that one out and if you're interested in
more biology study videos don't forget
to subscribe and hit that bell icon to
get notifications on new videos
so let's go ahead and get started
right here on the board i have drawn a
basic diagram of a chloroplast so before
we kind of delve into that
what exactly is a chloroplast well the
chloroplast is an organelle
it's found in plants or algae
specifically the you know these
chloroplasts are found in
organisms that conduct photosynthesis
so remember that photosynthesis it's a
metabolic process this is where light
energy is
converted into chemical bonds so that
carbon dioxide is fixed to make organic
molecules like glucose there are
um approximately
somewhere on the order of 30
to 40
chloroplasts per mesophyll cell and
leaves obviously there's going to be
variation between different kinds of
species and between plants and algae
so now let's take a look at the
structure of these chloroplasts i'm
going to basically start right here with
the outer membrane it's labeled a
and we will work our way around these
labels until we get to the final one k
the starch granule
so let's start by talking about that
outer membrane you'll see there are two
membranes there's an outer membrane an
inner membrane there's an inter membrane
space between them and then everything
else is inside that inner membrane
so the outer membrane
this is particularly porous like a lot
of stuff can get through that outer
membrane and it is evidence for
something called endo
symbiosis now i have another video on
endosymbiosis or the endosymbiotic
theory
where we learn about the different types
of evidence including the outer membrane
also the 70s ribosomes we'll talk about
in a little bit
evidence for
basically the evolution
of mitochondria and chloroplasts from
endosymbiotic events so if you're
interested definitely check that video
out now inside the outer membrane there
is the inter membrane space it's just
kind of this small like fluid filled
compartment and it is mostly empty like
there's there's fluid but otherwise it's
pretty empty
and then inside that we've got the inner
membrane the inner membrane regulates
passage in and out a lot more so
movement of things from outside the
chloroplast remember outside the
chloroplast is going to be the cytoplasm
of the cell
and then inside the chloroplast right
here the inside kind of compartment is
like a fluid filled
area known as the stroma so the inner
membrane does a much
better job at regulating passage you
know in and out
of these compartments than the outer
membrane does so the inner membrane
in addition to regulating that passage
in and out is also an a location for
synthesis of important things
particularly certain lipids
and
carotenoids
you may have heard of carotenoids these
are basically like accessory pigments
that are there to
absorb kind of excess wavelengths of
light during photosynthesis to basically
protect the leaf tissue
next we'll talk about the stroma
remember the stroma
is like the fluid filled compartment
inside the inner membrane where all this
other stuff is located it also has the
correct enzymes and a suitable ph
for the calvin cycle
now if you've studied photosynthesis
really in any kind of detail you know
what the calvin cycle is it's also known
as the light independent reactions or
sometimes called the dark cycle and this
is where carbon dioxide is fixed into an
organic form
that eventually supports like the
synthesis of
glucose and other organic
molecules
so also that portion of photosynthesis
the calvin cycle happens in the stroma
and again i think i said this the stroma
is quite aqueous or fluid filled it can
have kind of a gelatinous type
consistency because there is so much
kind of dissolved in it you know all
this stuff
next we'll talk about the thylakoids so
singular for that is thylakoid plural by
the coins you just add that s
this
basically um each one of these things
that i've drawn in green is a thylakoid
like that's a thylakoid that's a
thylakoid that's a thylakoid that's a
thylakoid that's a thylakoid that's a
thylakoid even the longer ones the
lamellae that we'll talk about later are
sometimes called thylakoids
so in green we've got our thylakoids and
these are basically these
like fluid-filled sacs
and they contain the electron transport
chains atp synthases and chlorophyll
for the light reactions
of photosynthesis
and specifically this is in their
their membranes okay so the membranes of
the thylakoids hold all of these
necessary components
to drive the light reactions sometimes
these are also called the light
dependent reactions they are a part of
photosynthesis that basically precedes
the calvin cycle
so again if you study photosynthesis i
think you you kind of already know how
to distinguish the calvin cycle and
light reactions
but the inside space
um like inside these thylakoids the
inside space is called the lumen
and we often talk about the lumen
particularly when we're talking about
the electron transport chains and the
atp synthases because it is the the
basically the buildup of hydrogen ions
on one side of the thylakoid membrane
that creates a gradient that powers the
atp synthases so if you're studying
the light reactions you're often talking
about the lumen and you know what's
happening in the lumen versus the stroma
okay now let's talk about what a stack
of thylakoids is called a stack of
thylakoids like this one right here it's
called a granum
so we have a gram here another gram
another gram another gram another gram
and so these are the stacks of
thylakoids the plural form is
grana excuse me so you're talking about
just one it's a granum ending in um if
you're talking about multiple of these
they're called grana so you know that
the um each
chloroplast has multiple grana that are
these stacks of thylakoids
why do these things exist they are here
to increase
the surface area
to volume
ratio
so basically the thylakoids
they get organized into these grana and
all of these thylakoids
each thylakoid has all of these
different um
membranes and this really increases the
surface area to volume ratio because
remember it's in these membranes
that you have all of these important
components embedded and the more
membrane you have the more
you know efficient and effective these
light reactions are if you want to learn
more about surface area to volume ratio
i also have a video on that topic that
goes into a lot more detail so check
that out next we'll talk about the
lamellae so
singular is lamella
a little bump in the house there uh
singular is lamela
plural is lamela you just add that e at
the end
and this is a specialized term
for these thylakoids that you see that
are quite um long and will kind of
connect
like one gram to another gram so like
this one right here is kind of
connecting this gram to this gram so the
lamellae are a way to connect grana and
kind of make um
just like a nice interconnected system
here
and so the lamellae that connects the
grana sometimes these will be called
stromo
thylakoids um as opposed to like granola
thylakoids so you might hear
you might hear sort of this being called
a thylakoid but this being called a
lamella or you might be
hearing this right here called a granola
thylakoid and this being called a
stromal thylakoid so they just have some
different terms occasionally
now let's talk about h over here this is
drawn in pink you can see i've drawn um
two of these in this particular like
diagram of a chloroplast
this is the chloroplast dna sometimes
called cp dna
and so cp dna
that's the abbreviation you've got
typically dozens or even hundreds of
these
per chloroplast i've drawn two so you
have to imagine dozens or hundreds of
those packed in here so very important
and each of these is going to have you
know somewhere on the order
of 100 to 200 genes that's going to
depend on
the
um
on the particular species
so 100 to 200 genes on dozens to
hundreds of copies per chloroplast every
copy is going to be identical
uh what else was i going to say
there's also so these 100 to 200 genes
they do
provide the information for a lot of
what happens in the chloroplast but
there are also things in the chloroplast
that are the the products
or controlled by genes in the nuclear
dna so the nuclear dna still contributes
to some of these processes
then you're going kind of next on our
diagram we're going to this one
ribosomes i've drawn several little
ribosomes in red
these are 70s
ribosomes we say 70s this is like a
sedimentation unit or a stenberg unit
this is to distinguish the ribosomes
that are in mitochondria and
chloroplasts which are 70 s ribosomes
from eukaryotic ribosomes that are in
plants and animal and fungal and
protozoan
uh cytoplasms basically
which are ads
and this right here the fact that these
are different that these are more
similar to ribosomes from prokaryotes so
bacteria
is another big piece of evidence for
endosymbiosis so again if you're
interested in learning more about that
check out my video on
the endosymbiotic theory but these
ribosomes their main function is to
translate the proteins that are encoded
by the chloroplast dna so chloroplast
dna will be transcribed there will be
some some rna
that will go to the ribosome and be
translated to make proteins that are
important in the various functions
that are being carried out
in this photosynthetic process
in the
chloroplast
next we've got plastoglobuli
now singular is plastoglobulus
plural plastoglobuli i've drawn them
here in blue
i have put kind of some
horizontal lines just to distinguish the
blue and the purple circles um
particularly for people who may not be
able to see those colors um very
distinguishably
but so i've just drawn some like lines
through these but that's just to help
you visually separate them not to
indicate anything particular about their
appearance
because these plasto globulin they're
really just spherical bubbles of lipids
and proteins okay spherical bubbles
containing lipids and proteins involved
in synthesis and breakdown of various
things that are important to
chloroplast function think vitamin e
carotenoids chlorophylls etc and they're
also important in mediating the stress
response
so
when a cell is under stress
um chloroplasts can change you know how
they're functioning to respond to that
stress and plasto globulin
you know have basically the components
that allow them to make those those
different responses
finally we're going to do the last one
we've made it to the end start granules
the the
couple of things you should remember
about starch granules those are
indicated just as kind of purple
spheres or ovals in my diagram
these do not have a membrane
so there's no membrane
and they grow throughout uh
the the day and then they're consumed at
night so during the day they're getting
bigger bigger bigger bigger bigger
and at night they're going to get
smaller why is this well starch granules
remember the point of photosynthesis is
to use that light energy convert it into
chemical energy basically to the bonds
that are
holding all of that carbon you know
fixed from the carbon dioxide into
organic molecules like glucose those are
stored kind of temporarily as starch
and so these starch granules contain the
products of the photosynthesis the
photosynthesis that's happening during
the day when there's light available to
power those light reactions
um
allows the the glucose and you know to
be made glucose and other sugars and for
it to be stored in the form of starch
and so those starch granules as the
glucose is being made and converted into
a starch form they're getting bigger
bigger bigger
and then at night they're being consumed
they're being used
so they're being consumed each night via
the process
of respiration cell respiration aerobic
respiration
um different terms for that process
uh so they're being consumed via
respiration this is to make atp
for you're not not just the not just the
chloroplast right but for the whole for
the whole organism for the whole cell
so they can either be consumed via
respiration if they're needed like in
that location or they can actually be
exported to the phloem and shared with
the rest of the with the rest of the
organism with the rest of the plant
and these things can get so big during
the day that they can even be up to 15
of the entire chloroplast volume so you
can see these starch granules i mean
i've had to draw them fairly small just
to fit them in but as that
photosynthesis process is going these
things are going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and can take up a
quite large like i said over 15 percent
of the chloroplasts um
volume
now i do also have a video on
comparing photosynthesis and cell
respiration so if you want to see kind
of how photosynthesis compares to the
cell respiration process that would be
another one to check out there were also
those videos on the surface area to
volume ratio and on the endosymbiotic
theory
and so those would also be great ones to
watch along with my video on the
structure of mitochondria
so that is going to be it for today
thank you very much for watching biology
professor and don't forget to subscribe
and i will see you next time bye